━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
内藤忍の資産デザイン研究所メール＜第六百九十六号2026年8月7日（金）発行＞
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆様に提供するウィークリー・メールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとする実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的方法を可能な限り客観的な視点でご紹介いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
内藤忍公式ブログ
内藤忍、株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行いますが、金融商品の勧誘・推奨などの投資助言業務は一切行っておりません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
【メルマガ先行募集】【無料】堅実な不動産投資で資産を増やす方法を60分で伝授します（9/14）
12年続く毎回好評の定番セミナー
9月も追加開催決定です
10名限定で東京ミッドタウン六本木で開催
総投資額20億円でわかった！
「不動産投資必勝法」
失敗しない物件の選び方、お金の借り方がわかります
不動産投資未経験者・初心者におススメです
詳しい内容とお申込みはこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ
3　読者の質問コーナー
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
5　資産運用日記
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍の公式ブログ Shinoby`s World コラムタイトル一覧＞
毎日更新している公式ブログの、前回メールマガジン配信以降のコラムです。
こちらから全文をお読みいただけます
8月1日 「年功序列」にこだわる人は「老害」に陥る
8月2日 悩ましい被災時のペットのケア
8月3日 「マリオットの奴隷」が「株主優待おじさん」から学ぶべきこと
8月4日 「Die with Zero」が不可能な２つの理由
8月5日 プライスレスな価値を生むワインとウイスキー
8月6日 高市首相に代案も出さずイチャモン付ける人たち
8月7日 「ニーサ貧乏」という言葉に騙されてはいけない
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍のメディア出演・出版情報＞
【毎月更新】マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」
最新コラムタイトルは
「「1ドル＝200円」時代も覚悟。
資産配分を見直し、事前準備を」
連載一覧はこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
食料品しょうひ税減税が日本経済を破壊する
高市首相は食料品のしょうひ税の1％への引き下げと中低所得者への1％の給付によって実質ゼロ化を進める方針を政府決定しました。
私はそもそもしょうひ税の減税自体に反対ですが、今回の食料品に限定した減税は日本経済に様々なマイナスの影響をもたらすと考えています。
まず、言うまでもなく財源の確保なき減税は財政基盤を毀損し、金融しじょうのリスクを高めます。
食料品の減税は年間5兆円きぼの税収減を伴うため、財源不安からの国債売り（金利上昇）や円安のリスクが懸念されます。
そして事業者に対する負担の増加も懸念材料です。
期限付きの税率の変更は小売業者や飲食店によるレジシステムの変更や会計しょりの改修に負担がかかると言われています。
飲食店のイートインとテイクアウトの税率の差が大きくなれば、外食を控える人が増え売り上げ減から廃業する飲食店も増えそうです。
さらに今回の減税は2年間の期間限定としていますが、2年後の首相は誰になっているか分かりません。
果たして、2年後の政権はしょうひ税を元に戻すことができるのでしょうか？
しかもせっかく減税しても、らいねんの3月までの物価の上昇で減税メリットはほとんど感じられなくなりそうです。
ポピュリズム政治で日本経済がさらに悪化していくのが心配です。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・イベントのご案内
【メルマガ先行募集】【無料】堅実な不動産投資で資産を増やす方法を60分で伝授します（9/14）
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
3　読者の質問コーナー
読者からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリ回答いたします！
Ｑ：不動産小口化商品「みんなで大家さん」が問題になってます。
投資詐欺に騙されないためには何に気をつけたら良いでしょうか。
Ａ：ご質問ありがとうございます。
「みんなで大家さん」のような不動産小口化商品の問題やトラブルから学ぶべき事は高利回り投資商品に必ず存在するリスクを認識することです。
投資の基本原則はハイリスク・ハイリターンです。
高利回りであるということはそれに伴うリスクが必ず存在することを忘れてはいけません。
高利回り元本保証商品のような都合の良い金融商品は存在しません。
また不動産であれば配当の原資となるインカム収益の裏付けを検証してみることが重要です。
例えば投資対象となる不動産の賃料収入が周辺相場と比べて不自然に高く設定されていないか。
あるいは未完成の大型開発案件であれば、完成前に収益を生み出すことはできません。
キャッシュフローを生み出していないのに配当を約束するのは自転車操業になっている可能性があると考えるべきでしょう。
さらに不動産小口化商品には流動性リスクも存在します。
現金化することが難しい資産に購入者から大量の解約請求が入れば対応できなくなってしまいます。
商品の中には広告に著名人を起用したり、大量の広告宣伝費をかけているものもあります。
しかし、裏返せばそれだけのコストが商品価格に載せられていることを意味します。
自分自身が商品の仕組みやリスクを完全に理解できない商品には資金を投じない。
そして投資する場合も分散を心がけ資金を集中させない事が投資の基本です。
このコーナーでは読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所だいひょう取締役の内藤忍がメールマガジン上で回答いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
相変わらず最高の新橋にある隠れ家カウンターイタリアン
新橋にあるカウンターイタリアンのお店に2年ぶりに出かけました。
こちらは駅から少し離れた閑静な場所にあり、マンションのインターホンを押して店内に入る仕組みです。
同じビルの1階にあるお寿司屋さんのグループなので新鮮な魚介類が食べられます。
この日は、冷製コーンスープから始まり、名物の前菜の盛り合わせ、ビスマルクピザ、気まぐれパスタ、そして、宮崎牛のステーキと質量ともに大満足でした。
前菜の盛り合わせは、この日は9種類。
新鮮な魚や、パテドカンパーニュなどバリエーション豊かなお料理が少しずつ1つのお皿に美しく盛られています。
宮崎牛は口の中でとろける味わいが赤ワインにとてもよく合いました。
デザートのティラミスと一緒にコーヒーではなくイタリアのデザートワインも注文でき、これですっかりお腹がいっぱいになりました。
ワインも充実しており、グラスワインが赤白それぞれ5種類ずつ。
どれもセンスよくお料理に合わせたおいしいワインでした。
駅から少し離れたわかりにくい場所にありますが隠れ家感満載の楽しいお店です。
2、3人の会食やお店を貸し切っての食事会など、使い方は自由です。
朝の5時まで営業してので、2次会、3次会の利用にも使えそうです。
ただし小さなお店で、周辺にはお店がほとんどないので事前に連絡してから出かけたほうが無難です。
ちなみに変わった店名ですが、由来が知りたい方はアルファベットの名前を右から読んでみてください。
イジョコタス
東京都港区新橋6-13-3 スズラボ新橋ビル 2F
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。